foreign
and I were just coming out of we just
went for a drink at a place that I've
been to many times really close to my
gym I'm in a nice neighborhood and we
just had a drink and we were walking
back to my car and he was gonna go home
and I was gonna go home
and um as we were walking down the
street I just I got hit and fell to the
ground was knocked unconscious
um it happened really fast kind of out
of nowhere he just threw a aluminum
water bottle and it hit my face it was
it was hurled pretty hard
and um it just it just got me just
knocked me right in the head I was on
the ground
all I knew that is all I knew that was
bleeding I didn't really feel any pain
at the time I thought we were still
being sort of attacked in some way and
so I managed to call 9-1-1 I was very
calm but I was also very sure I was
going to die
my head I was like I'm gonna just try to
verbalize a report of what's happening
so there's some record of How I died
no policeman came
I do not hold the police accountable for
this at all I hold our city accountable
for defunding the police and making it
you know um
we're in this situation where we don't
have enough police force to protect our
citizens and we did this to ourselves if
we don't have police officers to come to
the to the side of somebody who is under
attack
then we're all on our own
the guy I was with is six seven
um tall strong guy I think I honestly
credit him for saving me I
um
he says that
what I've tried to piece it together
afterwards he said that the perpetrator
the guy the uh you know the guy who
attacked me was still coming towards me
or us and he turned around and really
aggressively yelled at him and the guy
ran away but it was still sort of an
attack happening and had it not been for
this person being with me it would have
I think been a lot worse he really tried
to convince me to go to the hospital you
know he's a physician too and he was
like you know you need to go to the
hospital you need to go to the hospital
I didn't want to be sitting in a waiting
room bleeding with this contusion
confused and sort of sitting there
waiting for some sort of medical care I
wanted to get home so I decided just to
get the heck out of there and go home
and I felt like I could take care of
myself and I
I arguably needed a head CT but in the
end it turned out fine
I'm not so concerned with myself I'm
concerned with my friends I'm concerned
with my kids I'm concerned with
everybody walking around downtown I care
about people I care about every single
person in the community
um no matter what color flag you wave
um and who you are where you live I and
I
get angry thinking that this could
happen to anybody I care about or
actually just anybody even if I don't
know them